salvo le persone dell'internet ciao
amici che bello quando ti fai la barba
ma non ti sai fare la barba e quindi e
quindi di squarci anche la famiglia però
va bene non fa niente datemi il secondo
che dovesse funziona qua che non
capiscono mai come cazzo si fa lo
youtube in un video faccio youtube che
faccio finta di ferrari ciao ciao gente
ciao amici come state solo sono in live
anche la vista preso bene se l'hai a
persona [ __ ] da farle live voi non fu
gustatevi sul cratere che filtra di
vendere non ci sia niente
ciao persone come state allora voglio
dirvi in europa l'ultima volta che ho
giocato outlast che ha fatto un successo
della madonna ha fatto un milione di
views il finale di aulas fa chi è
grazie non pensavo se stai guardando
questo streaming poi quando già finito
schifate direttamente al minuto dove
iniziò gate mentre adesso facciamo
cinque minuti di chilling together
perché all'inizio meglio fare così
perché almeno la gente arriva così siamo
tutti insieme così giochiamo tutti
quanti insieme
poiché i ragazzi quindi aspettiamo che
arrivi gente lo spediamo cinque minuti e
35 minuti partiamo today giochiamo a
little nightmare ragazzi meter knight
non sarebbe tipo mi sembra un incrocio
tra inside the inside non che è piaciuto
a tutti e among the sleep pure quella
era piaciuto a tutti quindi un mix delle
due cose
se non vi piace siete dei buffi dei v
day but siete ci siete ciao belli
chiamate anche la nonna che domenica
tanto non è ammessa chiamate la nonna
vederla live di te non c'è famiglia in
live che si connette subito una materia
e
sì perché dovevo detto cazzo non
facciamo è primis facciamo tipo una live
così oggi che andava di farla mai quindi
oggi niente è previsto che gioia di
vivere la son contento che non e scelte
visto non avete idea comunque ragazzi
non lo gioco tutto l'iter nightmares
perché sarebbe tipo non so quanto dovrà
d'ora tipo b 4 ore non ne ho la piu
palmi un suo conto di dura di quel
nightmares quindi facciamo una live oggi
e poi magari lo continuo sempre in live
durante una settimana tipo mercoledì
fare un altro live sull'iter nightmares
ok raga mazzanti siete o porca vacca su
questi 20 mila persone sapere che tipo
20mila le persone la metà dello juventus
stadium
se tutti quanti chiamate un amico a
vederla live vi raddoppiate il che
potrebbe mandarmi in pappa il cervello
però ok grandi grazie grazie che mi
seguite grazie amici
ciò che non ci credo c'è il caso lo
scratch sullo schermo della volta scorsa
ci è rimasto così un po come quando che
quando è anche camera mia e rimasta in
disordine come la volta scorsa
da quando abbiamo fatto là degli awards
non ho pulito niente uguale anche lo
sketch dello schermo di nostro questo va
bene non ha senso ma ok farcia che bello
con gli streaming di domenica
bell stì musicale avevo hai un bel east
i muscoli per ne ha rubati
che figata sta roba dello scratch adesso
facciamo stare
faccio tutto il gameplay così rimango
così tutto il tempo ragazzi tutto ha
[ __ ] tempo non c'è il domenica
migliore di questo secondo me vai vai
chiamate gente che troppo partiamo sono
le 16 03 16 05 si parte per questo
gameplay bellissimo write
che bello perché faccio una faccia
un instagram stories dove dico che siamo
in live spese almeno tutti quanti quelli
su instagram poi vedono alla live
ragazzi sorridente sede di vista che non
stories ancora prima che io lo faccia
siti prescelti bel haga sono in live
streaming se non è piaciuto guardare
percorrere equa sede live streaming se
non vi connettete alla live siete brutte
persone quindi connettetevi alla rai che
adesso grazie io faccio così lei sta lei
staiano stories sono una persona
simpatica la persona simpatica
mi chiamo siamo arrivati a 2 milioni mi
chiamo quanto era truzzo come con uscita
siamo arrivati a 2 milioni su instagram
raga grazie grazie per i 2 milioni siete
wow
siete super super super wow fra vigili
attivare donazione è non solo si fa
adesso sono io io sei ignorante non so
fare io sono uno il tuo 4 vieri iscritti
quasi non so fare di più per non so come
sia tattili quella roba da poi vediamo
poi vediamo oggi giochiamo fotte sega 17
mila ragazzi io direi che possiamo
partire
chiamatele people che oggi giochiamo un
gioco bello tutti insieme ci siete
allora fatemi entrare quale attimo
perfetto ragazzi siamo sull'iter
nightmares non so se c'era non so cosa
cosa aspettarmi perché non ho visto
mezzo gameplay non ho visto niente ma so
che è molto molto molto simile a inside
che abbiamo già giocato quindi dire che
possiamo partire oa nuova partita sono
sempre citato quando lo facciamo anche
il primo ora che non so perché tutti
quei bambini quando i racconti le storie
so credo che sia un gioco incentrato
sulle paure dei bambini dicono società
bambino che si immagina le cose credo è
poi buono non ne ho idea
bella roba tutta scura vedo gesù
mascalzone gesù tutto è che chiunque
meno che gesù sto tizio cos'è sta roba
la partenza è very nice
a sono io in pigiama tu sei una
continuano a causa dei capelli c'era
prendi non consone se capita era la mia
prof
nei porti matematica che era un sogno
no dai nomi di così ma cosa ma come mai
ma quanto vivo dentro una valigia la
come perché dal minimo dentro la valigia
ul haq doveva pensava non l'ho capito mi
sa cercare con joystick che sono pigro
non ci vuole giocare alla tastiera
dominazione calcio se ce l'hai già
partite iva inside già partito
cos'è era un incubo quello che sono
tornare i tuoi normalmente non sono
capaci vediamo se riesco a farlo
questi cazzo di cogliere la tastiera o
lei chi è
so già inciampato ho fatto un mezzo che
ci ha fatto bene si vede tutto a posto
posso iniziare si ok ma riprende allora
ragazzi siamo svegliati c'è questo
bellissimo impermeabile giallo che usava
anche walter white breaking bad
bisogna fare anche figo e va bene posso
prendere gli oggetti becca dista scatola
di fagioli perché è un po tutto a
cellino per questo bambino a un [ __ ]
a cellino cosa fa i fumi a 8 anni
non ti fai schifo resisterò cosa siano
ma che figata ragazza bellissima
lamentazione
inside l'avevo detto che era simile
inside questo scommetto che posto dagli
e vago non così non so i comandi aiuto
ma fatelo tutorial a cosa fatta ad
accendere ok allora sono impedito
accendi porca eva a mariah non so
veramente non sei comandi certo un
problema di fondo
messo permesso devo andare a scuola
mamma cioè la colazione a casa sua amica
non mi vedevo frutta story bello
strisciare li condotti all'inizio del
gioco mi piace un sacco tipo metalli e
doccia la mattina un po di shampoo o le
ma mai preparato i pancakes ma tra
l'altro suo bambino da dove si però stai
calmo sono cascato a un chilometro ma
perché ministro qui perché è un nano c'è
un bambino un anno che corre in mezzo a
un ambientazione conto ambigua e ragazzi
e inside è il side l'ambientazione è
uguale e il side cioè tipo il continuo
di inside riserbo o salve chi cazzo è
questo ciao zio posso darti fuoco per te
no
porca [ __ ] allora picchiano of a
tutta una bambola 500 euro su ebay
questo è un pezzo raro e sempre faccio
linea bambola tanto lo so già la granita
di gioco io mi blocco domandarmi vedere
qualche frutto delle persone perché non
sono capace a giocare mettiamola nella
pentola perfetto michele bron james
complimenti come che sia fatta lanciando
ad esempio no come ho fatto a lanciarla
primati
ari stronzo con me a vichy un'ora per
fare entrare alla statuina nella padella
cuciniamo cucina fa vj oggi la devo fare
io la colazione ragazzi man mano mi caga
treni a per saltare rt per afferma di
melo adesso che è un ora di gioco è
grazie però rt brafman era già accorto
però grazie
cosa devo fare i capi che su una sedia
pezzoni devo aprire potrebbero darla
solo andiamo là su afferrare prova anche
le sporgenze figo ok carta igienica
ma chi mi chiede che chi e che cosa
serve la carta igienica nella camera da
letto
salve non l'avevo vista lei che per ben
frontaloni per impiccarsi posso prendere
la sedia intanto non ti serve c'è l'hai
già usata grazie stavi aspettando la
ripresa quando aspetti troppo la
colazione di mamma che non arriva mai e
ti impicchi
grazie della sedia noi gentile la uso
per ora per la maniglia mi chiama e
tetro sto gioco pensavo fosse più
tranquillo penso fosse una roba un po
più child un po più non da restrizioni
di youtube che vuole intendere intenda
ok io non capisco perché il bambino ciao
ciao [ __ ] accendino stava andando
magari non è un bambino magari ci ha 30
anni e sto cristiano cazzo ne so io però
in anno quindi sembra un bambino
questo è il frigo ci sarà del pesce
avariato del 2000 oppure c'è la nutella
no ci sono delle scarpe
4 cosa devo smetterla di cercare le
scarpe nel frigorifero il caffè fedex
non capisco visto che le scarpe nel
frigorifero a ecco perché non trovava le
scarpe di tivoli prima si è impiccato
giusto cazzo denunciare la cosa più [ __ ]
visto gioco anche diversamente da inside
puoi muoverti su e giù ci puoi andare e
c'è la profondità quella verifica e me
ne frega una sega che ci sono delle
scarpe di amido arrampicare a sorrento a
capire le cose ragazzi scusate le prendo
le scarpe no fate 6
belli stilisti tetti di legno
ma cosa cazzo è sta roba
forse alien
c'è una caccia che anche di said dalle
larve e inside sul po basta inside basso
finito smetterò di dire la parola inside
del signor anti pro grazie uguale è
veramente un guasto alle larve anche qua
però neve che costano molto piccolo
quindi le larve sono grosse quantomeno
però ok che siete ecco che ci sono gli
haters più o meno è la stessa
conformazione di un header stato non
riesce a camminare in avanti è una larva
stupida va bene che belli i nemici sto
gioco delle larve
ok per adesso è poi non so portate non
ci siano ragnino abiti quel tipo
ok e allora siete stronzi sono state le
larve vero
aprite aprite che vi do fuoco la
famiglia possono usare il giornale posso
passare sopra ok no aprite bastati vi
denuncio le mi chiedeva andare ragabo
salto qua non è crosta sostanza una cosa
dovevo fare la forza e teneva le travi a
figlia che tega che volte li faccia un
preso ma che cazzo
e vabbè allora agile stronza pure cuba
che schifo
bene proprio una giornata e lunedì e
lunedì ragazzi vi sono svegliate per
andare a scuola lunedì per andare a
scuola e così quando ti svegli ed è una
giornata di merda acuti porca vacca nani
che corrono larve che mi attaccano
sono caduto nella in una pozzanghera di
petrolio tra l'altro sono messo già
pulito come possibile ma questi sono
salvataggi questi qua che donadoni dopo
completarsi sono salvataggi queste che
cazzo ne so io quindi così servono per
salvare la partita bene a figo fatto
bene ora cavalca suonano ha rotto il
cazzo te biancaneve perfetto il karma è
calma calma perché adesso continuo
camminate voglio vedere se va tutto bene
la live perché io quando mi pio quei
giochi non non so magari non sono andato
magari non avete visto niente all'inizio
del gioco proprio vedere se si vede si
vede bene c'era c'era un [ __ ] nano
beh ora gun
non ho idea di come ho fatto ad apparire
così no non accendo la noyes cacciava
cento
fanno vomitare queste cose brutte haters
levate cartone ma se vi prende una larva
cosa succedono via scoprire ma poi
scusatemi non aveva acceso check point
andò ricominciata la o quello del
salvataggio praga non capisco non so
magari non sarà un carcere solo per far
luce e buio non lo so
nano schifoso vieni qui vieni qua scarda
quanto sei brutto perché ci sono dei
nani bel problema visto che figata roba
che poi andare in profondità generator
che così non ce l'hanno mai
quindi in teoria che sorriso ogni disco
c'è questo non è un bambino non si
capisce chi minchia è qualcuno che lo
deve spiegare
ah se ci sono enigmi aspettatevi che io
mi blocking di determinato contraria
cioè c'è il sole
francesco sole perfetto no no no no no
no no no no no no no no
madonna che salto perfetto la prossima
volta che dici di di di usare veramente
le gambe se hai voglia
vorrei mai scomodarti troppo porca vacca
neanche quello è ora che non ci avevano
come faccia
ci riprova è mai ma posso correre non
posso correre non ci arrivo raga porca
eva come faccio la posso c'è un tasto
percorre perché questo è che questo è il
massimo dalla velocità per adesso no non
posso posso andare ancora più lento
non posso guardo gas come dr come ci
arrivo scusami non è che devo
arrampicarmi c'è qualcosa di buono
no
e non ci arriva un agguato
magari dimenticato c'erano cosa dovevo
prendere che non ha visto
tieni premuto hicks per scattare è dirlo
un'ora fa me lo dici adesso ma ci avrai
la mamma brutta ma non avanti con calma
e le cose non so non ho di me con cap
puoi usare il joystick in questo gioco
grazie di melo alla fine minchia che
party game e subito le cose che mi fate
perder tempo avete un attore cazzo siete
7 sette nani siete sette apparizioni di
dopo e non più e poi vi denuncio già
metterlo java javascript turcato
stonando lo dico io
premesso ciò a causa dei nani qua tra
nani e larve non so cosa peggiora gabra
ok
ecco quello mi sa che è incazzato
leggermente credo e non sono sicuro
troppi sempre incazzato cosa c'è qua
raperonzolo rape stronzo comunque non ho
capito l'ho chiesta gente dove sono io
da temere una spiegazione maledizione
cos'è una prigione questo dio a farvi
salvarmi salvare non ho ancora capito se
salva sta roba un meno ma va bene io
salvo credo di sì perché compare l'icona
in basso a destra però non è permesso e
intoppi ma perché il suo gioco c'è la
carta igienica ovunque quale problema
perché a questo successo la nostra
questo qua ra qua ha senso la carta
igienica perché un bagno
ecco questo cia la fobia di dimenticarsi
con dove tipo finisce la gara finisce al
rotolo non avete più la cartella e
questi c'è una utopia
se ne portate mille del processo possa
alzare la tavoletta in salsa posso mi
fate vedere cosa c'è dentro
quindi che cosa c'è dentro la tavoletta
non me lo fa ventre peccato allo vedere
tutti gli haters all'interno guardati
intorno usando rs avevano scoperto io da
mo perché si aspetta che me lo dici tu
gioca un'altra roba
[Musica]
paranormal carta igienica vuoi essere la
protagonista del video zio voi le news
televita casa sta dondolando sta roba è
una nave mi sa forse siamo in una nave
mi deve incazzare ma ditemelo metti melo
sotto con il tutorial fatiscenti deve
incazzare incasso in ritardo per un
incasso senso magari magari se se guardo
le cose prima di atlas vedeva lontano un
chilometro di quella roba folgorava sono
io che sono un [ __ ] prove dove vai
topo vai a cercare gli haters nel cesso
non ci sono qua ci sono sono già
distruzione larve questo gioco sonlar
degli haters questo fa devo togliere la
corrente
comunque non ho capito perché in fondo
la roba siamo in una nave enorme che
figata dato con la carta igienica
laddove era uscita lo sa solo lei mentre
cadevo togliere la corrente come renzo
c'è il pannello lì sicuramente la
pannello le forze usa la carta igienica
come come slancio
ecco no scherzavo
no non posso farlo io la chiamo rosso se
quel cavo rossa dietro la porta
ok più di me c'era una leva della nostra
nuova amica vista
e così il titanic affonda subito dopo
in realtà questa è la titanica e
affrontato così non lo sa nessuno ma
sono stato io
perché a tempo
pensate se devo muovermi deve succedere
qualcosa
e mica quanto tempo quanto tempo avevo
premere attraversare quel punto un'ora e
mezza a no perché c'è anche qui
giustamente io stavo fermo bravo bravo
famiglia gallo rincoglionito sapevo io
che devo muovere il culo e ma come torno
indietro dal google dal buco nel muro
perfetto mi sembravi sembrava un po
troppo il tempo di ciao mi chiamo quanto
tempo hai per ci riesce anche mia nonna
passare in tempo facciamo così comunque
ragazzi sto gioco è uscito per limite
quando uscito autras è mica in un anno
non esce mai niente di giochi horror
nulla
tutti insieme poi da un momento
all'altro ti insieme escono c'è
incredibile veloci veloci sui bot
bravo bravo che non corri così veloce
neanche quando c'è la patata bravissimo
ma siamo in una nave comunque ragazzi
per forza che dondola sta roba
la persona cercando di capire perché
vedo cabine rosa
[Musica]
picche
sono morto
sono diventato di pietra
4 ma quante carne ha fumato già il
creatore visto gioco quante c'è stata
stabilita vi sballo pesante quando hai
programmato sta roba zio cioè ma ti
rendi conto cosa stava perché per quale
motivo per quale motivo alla luce di 20
pietra eccoli sono caduti circa scati
perché è capito ha quindi devo fare
attenzione muovermi mentre
ok a c'è un occhio mi chiamavano anche
visto perfetto già fatta
credo si sia fatto effetto
accendi ok che conte tetra sta roba
stanotte cio gli incubi quello di bo
genere perché qui si giochi senza già si
chiama che ci hanno l'atmosfera or vi
mettono di paura che giochi con i jazz
per un gesù
bella zio ben e zio che sei senza gambe
no in realtà ce le ha le gambe solo che
sono sproporzionate col corpo non è
l'unica causa sproporzionata mica
pensavo che avesse visto che stavo
cadendo in mano forte bene è passato poi
al passato picciò da qua c'è un bambino
sopra soletto cosa ci sono dei bambini
che dormono comma 9 per regalarmi ce sto
gioco veramente per me era sotto effetto
di droghe pesanti e lo ha fatto sul
serio
sono i bambini che si rotolano però
vedete che io non sono un bambino perché
sono ancora più piccolo di un bambino
cioè io ve lo dico ragazzi suo
personaggio cuocia 30 anni mio questo
con l'impermeabile giallo
tanto lo dico io che già 30 anni sembra
bambino ma non lo è e magari non è
neanche un maschio che era solito si
capisce non parlano i suoi giochi dicono
niente
c'è gente con le braccia lunghe chi era
quel che porterà brutto poi
chissà se se la fagiana barba e se mi
puoi insegnare a non tagliare milano ti
facciamo ballo la prova i dettagli
vi chiederete fare in altri casi di fi
la barba che non ha i baffi e la faccia
per chi sembrare più grande almeno una
parvenza di un adulto sticazzi di topi
mal di stomaco è e sarà il sushi
avariato ii e in teoria perché cerca di
droga gare sei passata accesso prima non
potevi fare una capatina no già che c'è
lì vai al centro che ci sei caga non so
palla per terra che se vuoi tanto non è
casa mia
sarà pertanto non si vede nessuno zio
siamo sono in ventimila in live non è
solo o salve salvezza per caso dove il
sesso che vi sto pagando addosso dov'è
il cesso scusi amaci ha fame non mi sto
pagando addosso hai fame è la mamma l'ha
fatta ok grazie buono questo pane
integrale
mica variato anzi sfornato poco poco fa
grazie dio sa molto gentile
sei tutto nero e dentro ma io non sono
razzista sono gt anzi 26 gentile con me
grazie adesso devo pagare fortissimo mi
dici dove accesso canzone poco
tranquilla e partita non essere triste o
almeno tu non devi correre al cesso io
sì ma questo è un bambino è uno come me
anche lui ci ha 30 anni bello aiutarsi
tra nani sostegno tra noi ragazzi c'è
una corda per impiccarsi
facciamo che non mi serve anche perché
non quella corda dice faccio l'altalena
io sono veramente piccolo ok le docce è
bene e ben strutturata stanare bombe
nota anche palle per chiede con la roba
con l'elettricità che maroni veramente
mi chiamo dobbiamo fare tutto io doveva
lettrici sull idraulico devo pagare io
pagare io come ho fatto a romperla che
però un netto sempre di più di quanto
pesi nella vita reale un bel regalo
ok
no era per sgranchirsi le gambe dovevo
fare il suo salto perché ero in botta
pensavo di essere spiderman nicchia nomi
sono partite le ragnatele capita di
essere anche tutti i bambini ci siamo
buttati a far spider man è poi finita
così l'altro vita non è che mi fa
ripartire da quel punto 9 devo fare più
di fare tutto ciò che è successo sono
scalzo non mi fa fare tutto a piedi nudi
far ripartire da lì ha almeno non edito
rifare il corridoio va bene non saltare
nel vuoto stavolta per cortesia
grazie proprio gentile
ok
di roman e schifoso no
detto
la cosa [ __ ] visto giù per ragazzi che
intuitivo cioè sai dove devi andare non
è come in tipo insight che capiva il
caso almeno so che sta andando giusto ok
i ragazzi intrigante voglio scoprire la
trama di sta roba di stato e siamo
non ho ancora capito è sincero non ho
capito se una nave non ho capito chi
sono chiesta gente però figo si può fare
qualcosa a nudo
non devo salire sulla scala che scusa
scende nella tasca lasko mettete
ma chi non ha capito fermi e quindi
dove cazzo sono caduto tra l'altro va
bene caso riuscito a ripescare il punto
di prima ma [ __ ] così indietro
avevo acceso il coso dai l'avevo acceso
il coso come mai così indietro ma qui
che sia veramente servono per salvare o
cos'altro servono perché mi sembra che
si funzionino tanto voglia farle dai
cheppallle l'odio la mia vita ha dato
tutto sto casino perché devo togliere la
corrente wow
devo seguire il cavo per toglierla corre
non avevo capito quindi alla fine si
deve pure di tornare giù
magari tornaci scendendo normalmente che
dice io non capisco questo fabrica
acceso che cazzola c'è da fare se non
serve a niente
o lega pro non sarò impedito però porca
di una eva non fosse un saggio zio di
risaltare non è difficile io un anno
saltavo non è difficile fare il salto di
merda non è che devi fare chissà cosa
c'era nel mondo
tutta roba che avrei tagliato vabbè
tanto vi faccio vedere porto solo in
realtà impedito nei videogiochi anche
coi tagli e sono in pericolo stesso però
godiamoci le appieno queste sensazioni
pelle di non riuscire a fare i soliti
giuro che se succederà trovata lancio
joystick cambia gioco giovanetti wins
cioè la roba scrausa della vita è più
dispero l'unica roba che riesco a
giocare decentemente pensate come
sommese come si correrà il ricordo più
così ok qui si salta o fallo
fai un salto che sia un salto cioè non
mi far incazzare
prima non andava bene prima cioè fammi
capire qual è il problema
comunque non ho capito a cosa serve la
roba l'iccat che mi sposta perché tanto
io la catena la posso salire lo stesso
no prova salirla dvd di brutto e dello
importa
o che non mi portare in sala parto che
vede
scusami allora qui dove dove vado non
capito dove dovrei andare
no
mica come mi sono salvato male come mi
sono salvato non so neanche io come ho
fatto va bene il tasto per aggrapparsi
ragazzi salva i culi non può fare che
ora scusate devo andare probabilmente a
destra però non ho capito
ha poi rimane così quindi corro
gesù cristo
fammi un checkpoint vicino porca vacca
che palle ma mi devo fare un chilometro
e mezzo da b the mission della pigrizia
sapevo io da una bocca che palle se non
sai saltare non sapevo ammettetelo il
salto se non si va gesù
raga
noi stiamo poi tutto il mio rigo cioè
siamo qua a tutta la vita io ve lo dico
siamo qua tutta la vita perché porca di
una [ __ ] non so fare un salto un
salto devi solo saltare se non è
difficile dice minchia di fare di
combattere un po se devo fare un altro
cazzone non è non è non è difficile
porca vacca laida si sposa un salto
maledetto per farmeli partire almeno da
sony che tu e maroni schifosi
salì ok
ma era giusta la tattica di prima che
dovevo spostato a sinistra cioè spero di
sì perché se non siamo qua un anno salta
cazzo fai che problemi hai zio
ok
harris come faccio a fare soltanto qua
occorrere così è per saltare no no no no
no no no no
ma la gara non so non penso ma è così
almeno non è che sapete è incredibile
non capisco io dove quella merda li
salto tipo un chilometro indietro non so
non capisco
pensate pensate se dopo lo faccio e non
è qui non c'è un cazzo dopo cioè non è
un check point che poi muoio bello sta
al gioco
mi sembra sembra faceva un po un
bordello di tassi non capisco piuttosto
cliccando
tentativo numero 429 ragazzi vediamo se
stavolta può essere quella giusta
qui non capisco dove cazzo devo saltare
[Musica]
allora sarà in traiettoria più o meno si
è dritto credo sia dritto poi troppo
indietro è troppo avanti tentativo
numero 1000 chiudiamo non vedete che qua
allora capire e qua a 9 decimi casa è
più è molto più indietro tornata a marzo
la famiglia a zero cioè ti faccio del
male fi entrò nel gioco ti schiaffeggio
forte e poi c'è rientro cazzo
[ __ ] al cuore 12 anni questa cagata qua
mi si è incredibile non ci posso credere
manco io e sembrava più avanti ragazzo
ma abbiamo anni butta ho sbagliato e la
profondità tpa per il kun il suo gioco
non capisci della roba se muoio mi fate
ripartiti con mi fa incazzare che dovrei
farmi tutto cio già ci sono riuscito per
miracolo castrato
ok così sta roba sigarette ecco bravo
usano l'accendino figura che sono grosso
quanto il posacenere bene se non va più
internet sono stato io è colpa mia
stato non serve un cazzo sta roba quindi
cosa facendo a fare c'è un nano mai
troppo l'altro vedo già bello di libero
è sì però mi chiamo grazie io libero i
nani questi corrono va bene auguri e
figli maschi e come si è chiusa la tetra
la porta li butto
ok a tornavo indietro figo la corda a
ferrara quando hai voglia perché io
clicca
io l'ho ficcato il tasto per afferrarla
è lui che non la terrà a hama e senza
corrente a ok ok non riga spesa cazzola
ha preso dall alba non pensavo di
dovermi rifare tutto da zero
ero convinto migliaia già stato
sbiancando ve lo dico invece no è giusto
così anzi ho fatto prima a buttarmi giù
io che che a scendere con la corda dammi
accendere che quest'anno gli haters
quindi alla fine le larve arrivano col
buio
credo di aver capito così insomma che
bello questo corridoi e la prima volta
che lo faccio perfetto o le applausi
laga grazie grazie grazie ma non troppo
gentili grazie ci ho messo niente
affatto
ok niente ma peccato è un cazzo di
sapevo io devo passare all'ombra giusto
poi vedo che i check point e rizzi ed è
qui che riparte tutto triste che faccio
devo seguire cosa del bidello era ci
arrivò a 0 allora non segue l'occhio
cosa viene poi meno male che dondola
quindi torno indietro si no ok bravo
bravo no cori però c'è bravissimo
[Musica]
assai quegli oggetti in movimento quello
schifo di ok buono a sapersi
poi mica si vede la luce
porca vacca questa notte è bravissimo
wow la prima volta che riesco a fare
qualcosa senza senza provarci mille
volte rega che traguardo inaghi giovani
va dove andate
lo linkiamo atteggiati siete da soli
almeno così è successo a un finto
livello a me alle pelli soggiorno figata
ma qui c'è poi un caricamento che storia
mi piace raga a me piace un sacco tranne
la parte l'ho fatto 26 volte mi piace un
botto
occhio che invece l'occhio anche qua lo
vedo la sopra quindi a livelli st matri
dice proprio quanti sono
[Musica]
messo comunque una nave senti hai rotto
il cazzo certo lo dico ti piglio ma se
via libera tivo perché scappate via
livatino prima di carpi che mi mangio s
dei nani cazzo nel frame mandato kosen
armi abiti del cielo dietro c'è una
porta nell'armadio ma state bene voi con
che sia una nave che ha confermato c'era
le prigioni adesso siamo usciti quindi
pian piano sacco di livello sulla nave
ci di livello nel senso di altezza è una
nave gigante comunque perché la perché
sono un piccolo però
[Musica]
auguri per la festa della mamma perché
la mamma del frutto di questo gioco
auguri auguri mamme dei creatori dei
videogiochi
perché anche chi crea i videogiochi alle
mamme no quindi anche chi ha provato lo
studio gioco aveva una mamma tanti
auguri mamma del creatore di little
nightmares tanti auguri cioè sono
riuscito a cadere da un punto dove non
si può cadere cellule che cazzo fatta
cadere
[Musica]
yeah perfetto no channing il cazzo
finite qua venite qua ti prego il premio
per la vacca danni del cazzo e dove
trovarli riguarda sono usciti dalla
valigia di gnosca mander fammi vedere le
creature che sono farglielo fare
climbing successo fightplan il successo
un dosato el aiuto c'è una chiave lì la
vedo è cosa cosa faccio
ma salta di qua proviamo beh devo mica
aprire in classe a non avevo capito
sorry ma perché ci agenti piccata susta
nave ma qual è il problema
ma siete tristi guardateli netflix non
mi sapete
ok non mi possa prendere sui quadri ben
bello scoprirlo adesso meno male non mi
farei partire all'inizio ti arriva uno
scafo cosa devo fare
c'è gente impiccate il suo gioco
comunque non capisco il senso poiché mi
dimentico sempre che possono aumentare
la visuale così posso vedere le cose è
che faccio però mi lancio sulle scarpe
un bilancio sul capo barca [ __ ] che
porta eolica devo provare che non
capisco dove andare per le tira uno
schiaffo
berisha ha c'è una leva quale avevo
visto che tanto non ci arrivo proprio la
valigia sia by news cannes under darci
la forza no
all è bello stu lett
sempre meglio del letto dove dormo
ragazzi comunque non avete idea di the
road ormai sta veramente si ok sembra
primo capitolo se non ci fossero le cose
da camicia di forza del 5 sul letto per
quale motivo non voglio saperlo bene
così
c'è l'ambientazione raga è veramente
paura o se fatto benissimo è stato qua
porca la madonna sono riuscita a fare
una roba decente sono sicuri che sta
giocando io ne faccio lista chiave più
grossa limena chiara bisogna buttare giu
non ho capito cosa mi deve servire a chi
altra ok stato ed è veramente troppo
grossa non posso affidarla nessuna parte
me la metto nel culo premio
scusami ma devo andare di qua posso
andare
da allora che cazzo serviva questo fatto
cosa ho fatto a fare piuttosto casinò a
ok allora si dà per carica era un ora
che verrà applicato sulle cose c'è anche
le pantofole erano rari bar applicano
sui sui cose poi non dovrebbe dovevo
passare il muro alla sede scemi
bravo perfetto proprio lì la volevo
andare ok ora sono un pò lento ma ce la
faccia siamo 80 era che non senza chiave
in anni dove sono andati ciao scimmietta
ma funziona questo rumore ma funziona la
scimmietta comunque peccato
non vedo con la luce con la luce vedo
meno di quando sono al buio vedo niente
devo arrivare lassù come ci arrivo bo
delle scarpe da scalare sta roba che ti
premuto per lager per lanciare un
oggetto raccolto intendi la loggia
lanciata la chiave i tutorial arrivano
con una latenza devastante
sto già lanciata la chiave lo so che
devo fare questa cosa qua devo lanciare
micah micah anche questo è un ragazzo
dalla ciotola rapporto su
ok e l'utilità di questa cosa
esattamente quale dovrebbe essere lo
devo portarlo sarà niente
c'è qualcosa ragazzo che non riesca a
prenderlo non sono scarpe di libertà per
nascere una lettera pronto va bene lo
lanciò a sul bottone ma non ci arriva
tanto stavo scherzando scherzando
non pensavo potesse lanciare le robe
dopo miratamente su qualcosa che il
cazzo di soia vita è un ascensore cioè
spiegami perchè una scelta va bene lo
vede saper porta la scimmia la scimmia
per tutta la gara scimmie la soluzione a
tutto il suo gioco lancia la sua scimmia
lancia scimmia bravo sì signori la
scimmia ricordatevi che se nei
videogiochi siete bloccati dovete
raccogliere le scimmie lanciando e sui
pulsanti a caso
ti senti osservata è no perché non ti
sto osservando comunque stiamo tornando
sotto conoscenza del pre dovremo andare
ciao dopo che nicolas tardo dovremmo
andare su in teoria non giu
hai ancora fame e non è mica una sera
foglia a 0 che palle
certo basta ho capito sempre fame ci sto
facendo venire parlamento sarà la donna
quanti topi comunque io in teoria dovrei
andar di sopra e non di sotto di sotto
sono già arrivato se no andiamo sempre
gli stessi posti
ce la fai a dare fuoco st romano
ciao bambino di prima che mi hai dato il
pane grosso bello buono non è che vi
scarci taralluccio niente è morto
la madonna mi chiamo manco avessi le tue
cose magari serve una pagnotta mi mangio
un topo morto
ecco appunto ciao topi miu miu quel
pezzo di carne grazie questa carne di
hamburger pregiato il 100 per cento dop
piemontese bravo zio magna che te va
bene stato sentite storia sono dei
bambini che cantano la cosa bizzarra
basta interno un po quadrive non vi
faccio vedere volte perché sono stronzo
cos'è nicchia ma hanno beccato rega
tiesto tizio
catturato un sacco di altri bambini come
me ma come anzi anche un pò più grossi
me quindi quella roba lì era una
calabria bambini ma è veramente poter
riuscire bastardi spacco il culo a tutte
le famiglie a mi chiamo madonna lega ma
viene data solo bene che ho fatto la rai
dove andata bene perché sapete qual che
avrei interrotto il video proprio in
quel punto lo sapete voi perché sono
strozzo però mi è andata bene che ho
fatto la rai quanto andata berigliano
volevo farla la rai visto gioco doveva
aspettare una settimana per l'altro
episodio una settimana vi facciamo
aspettare una settimana perché sono
bastardo dentro io andata solo per gli è
andata di lusso raga più deboli e non
sai con la suspense per una vita intera
che figata assurda vabbè comunque
chiesto tizio giusto per non lo so però
c'è la mamma [ __ ] anche lui ragazzi
so che siete intrappolati tranquilli ci
pensa zio favi che adesso va a prendere
a calci tutti quanti zio favi
mi ha schiacciato perché ore cioe mi ha
schiacciato
penso veramente che peccato io sono
morto perché ma schiacciato la porta a
teatro c'è un'altra di porta alla
sinistra avevo visto ha chiesto titolo
che belle manica e sexy dove lo sta
importando frate raga ci pensa lo zio
fare i quali verrà a tutti perché io
sono un condottiero
ok fattibilità dico che non ho capito
cosa c'è
a
vedi che non dovevi prendono l'ascensore
sono tornati dovremo prima perché sono
caduto al tromba delle scale sono vista
dalla parte opposta
ok niente quindi devo via inizio
dispiace che si spostano e frande
scusami poteva fare pure il depresso
[Musica]
ma siamo sicuri che devono correre poi
perché magari non devo comodo adesso ci
riprova pronti è
ok stavolta c'è stata quindi così shiva
l'altro io ho schiacciato prima per
scivolare non lo sapevo neanche così si
scivolava non avevo proprio idea bene
sono intrappolato è stata molto utile
questa scelta
bravo favi lo sa rampicanti che assume
lo sapevo
certo il soffitto sgangherato wow lui
chiama ghigliottina donna quanto è tetro
stato bravo sul complimenti maestria nel
centro di bucchi è anche tu per questa
porta così preso un triangolo casello
minati gli uomi la nave degli illuminati
ragazzi frate cei delle gambe che ti
giuro
in teoria non potevi farti le gambe le
braccia un po più corte le gambe più
lunghe
la braccia lunghe gambe corte e
l'uccello come sta messo non lo voglio
sapere
posso darti fuoco che mi sta in culo
infatti i cacciatori ayane melo pupi ma
mancato mercato vari cori territori ci
credo e mancato sul serio il cazzo che
salisse morto no non c'è qualsiasi
carico scarico ma quantomeno su carta
stiamo scherzando stiamo scherzando
aiuto frate fra frate frate no no no
facciamo tutti denunciati finti faccio
cazzo non mi toccare tanti denuncia dei
carabinieri ti faccio una penale così
tra il filo tutte nell'anno niente real
è poi ripartito triste dal dall'inizio
nella stanza perché è per quale motivo
la sesso staron ma quindi non ho capito
devo farmi prendere vittoria la c'è
qualcosa che esce
ha dato con l'altro perchè lui non può
vedere possono annusare che non ho
capito
cazzo mi sono cagato addosso mi sono
veramente cagato ai ragazzi come faccio
a coprire il mio dolore impossibile o mi
vesto la polcom non lo so come faccia a
deviarlo servizio
allora capiamo un attimo come fare fermi
il secondo
devo correre dylan sicuro
donna quanto a roma c'è in sostanza fare
un miliardo di robben ma devi correre
per questo per forte piero forse se
faccio piano no perché
è sempre quello dora cassa
ma cazzo
bay chay yew fucking o gp james irvine
cloud tipi your mother suck my fucking
belle ragazze ci abbiamo fatto ha preso
sta roba
nel triangolo degli illuminati yeah
quindi allora no non mi sento non
sentono l'odore ascolta cosa che ad essa
infatti sarà la rossa in libri prodotto
oppure si corre nel sito dovresti
correre per sicura dovrei anche buttarti
bene da andata bene che ha centrato il
buco stavolta e scherzando deposito di
scarpe questo scusami per i dispenser
della futur hooker grazie me né dai
un'altra che una non vi serve
vabbè che figata ragazze figata più o
meno prove
ti dovresti abbassare zio grazie no
quando vuoi e sono io che non sei tasti
dalla prole pato scommettete ma mi
spunta una mano e spuntano un po di
scarpe e rotta per ragazzi avete bisogno
delle scarpe no perché interviene
abbiamo per tutti gli iscritti e ne
abbiamo un paio per tutti chiamante
scarpe ci sono il costo cazzola quella
roba li na
madonna che mi sono salvato con sera con
la roma
potresti toglierti bene grazie a
saltargli la vero madonna come los
chiama così e lo squalo delle scarpe e
ma dove vado vado arrivare alla fine non
ce l'ha trova digiali bye bye bye bye
bye bye vede veloce l'agenzia facce mica
son lentissimo
perfetto mi chiama gasol fatto non ci
credo ok possiamo andar via
[Musica]
velocissimo è quella dove eravamo
rimasti
ma dai mica sto tornando indietro se io
vado avanti il suo gioco per poi tornare
indietro col cazzo
la scimmia scimmia la scimmia
vadano avanti è pronto legati a brutto
forte no a zio noti uno zio asta
proposta sta perdendo tempo che il
prezzo di merda in teoria potremmo anche
la p g sulla porta sai perché lì non
sono cosa al sicuro porca vacca quanto è
brutto
un anno è uscito al nano grandi e grandi
navi per una volta nella vita sono stati
tutti gli strani di merda perfetto
grandi i nani vedi che alla fine
serviranno a qualcosa a te pareva
machine mica la scimmia fa un casino
quando da furti ecco quella distrae di
brutto devo fare
spigno sta roba
[Musica]
e la madonna è andato il titolo ma qua
ci sono libri ci sono dei vari nascosti
però non lo sto trovando grandi dichiara
che la dieta trafficata sto gioco 9
bellissimo adesso è diventato veramente
figo midge ure finissimo quanto quanta
gente c'è a questi sono finti la bambina
è vero scommettere che la bambina è vera
[Musica]
c'è una scimmia dissenteria tocco la
scimmia posso fare casino insomma faccio
petroli
la sta facendo ma scemo cosa c'è la
bambina con la lisca non è vero la
bambina
andato via perfetto ok se volessi salire
qualche strano motivo la scatola
[Musica]
si inserirono dove se ne va bene una
bambola di prima che niente se questa
bambola che anche mi hanno trovato non
mi posso dire vabbè ma sta facendo
quello cosa fa è partita la scimmia dove
a questa scimmia è una scimmia zio
tranchida c'è la scala quando l'ho vista
facciamo così
[Musica]
merda merda come ha fatto a vedermi come
fatto i germi cosa ma non ha gli occhi
non può vedermi non è che ho sbagliato
guidano fossero cliccato toccato
qualcosa fatto casino porca vacca ma
visto va fa un cuore che sfiga poco male
adesso su come farlo bene
fatemi solo vedere tutto bene raga cola
live se diventa nero uno schermo
aggiornate la giornata youtube che
magari si impallano diventa per l'ultima
diventato nero lo schermo un periodo ma
barbara non serve un cazzo che non
avvento mi aveva detto che bambola non
casa si no non devi dare fuoco
prendi la prendiamo no
[Musica]
ma che collega grazie
tu mato mato norma nei cieli ma quello
cioè le braccia più lunghe del bene
va beh in teoria è normale avere per ciò
che le interessa 6 rocco perfetto
sono andato bene fa chi es
di chiacchiere strizza poi ragazzo è
orribile voler vagliare non capisco il
senso mentre io diceva che tipo è
[Musica]
ma passa mi chiama s'arrampica pure
babbi comunque alla luce forse possono
vedermi se vedono ma pochissimo forse è
bravo tempo più casino
porca [ __ ] lo sapevo io eh vabbè
allora
e quello che in legno fa casino ho
capito che le leggi
grande grandissimo cosa non è successo
adesso il legno fa casino ragazze
cammino sul legno faccio casino sapevo
da oggi ci voglio credere
meno male che ci sono cose che fanno
bordello
mischia che aveva preso al volo vlog pam
che ha fatto venire di là perché regina
di lava franco comunque non ho capito
cosa devo lanciare sul cosa non o
oggetti ci deve essere un oggetto
nascosta da qualche parte tipo che devo
lanciare su solo farmi cadere no sta
roba
c'è devo lanciare qualcosa sul bottone
perché ti lascio un bottone ma
semplicemente questo però non ho capito
cosa devo cominciare lo troveremo
qualcosa in giro ma bordello incoming
non avevo capito sta roba che sul legno
ma c'è il casinò raga scusatemi c'è la
stoffa del cammino giusto a scarpa forse
meno male che è qui sono partiti gli
orologi subito dopo che culo veloce sia
veloce giro veloce giro veloce anche
quello corre veloce però c'è contagia
tutto punta butta zio libri minchia che
bordello fa questo quando entra qua ed
help mi chiamo pianoforte ha diritto
se io faccio katherine che stanno
ammasso no chiedo si sa mai
no che vi sta ammazzando di nuovo
sentori accando sui tasti faccio un
bordello della madonna però in teoria
dovrei riuscirci terminazione adesso
bisogna fa vj sinfonia di beethoven
se magari ti arrabbi cassis uno sarebbe
male perché poteva devo andare
dall'altro che capitano tenetevi regala
questo salto che non riuscirà mai ma
veramente ci sono riusciti o io che
faccio un salto vero potrei stupirmi di
me stesso è zio hai veramente fracassate
di giuggioli
se vi giuro
è veramente cambiato il cazzo sto qua
c'era tanto le palle
speriamo che alla fine del gioco lo
ammazzo anzi speriamo anche un po prima
della fine degli occhi ancora sembra
novelle a triangolo e brutta situa rega
adottassi da questa
beh non ho capito se cammino poco sul
legno faccio portello
[Musica]
poi si sente che respira mica
bruttissimo
bravo dai
se faccio portello una vita qualche cosa
ma che cazzo fai padri non hanno preso
non ho preso su di se devi stare zitto
titoli tardi
se guarda sotto sono tanto sembra ce ne
sono
quando si guarda sotto una morto basta
tastare il pavimento basta ecco lo
sapevo io lo sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo
[ __ ]
mi fai partire dall'inizio di secca no
dice che siamo peggio
domanda ma dove dovrebbe essere sta roba
manovella schifosa che lo ritrovai
albero tanto qua faccio vedere c'è una
manovella
[Musica]
salì quanto tempo mamma mia che tragedia
sta roba
a [ __ ] mi faccio via dalla roma in
testa c'è la scimmia ecco la scena era
utile prima
adesso però far portello madonna
la scimmia ragazzi la terrei perché
serve meno male che ha pestato una roba
allora devo trovare quello schifoso di
un meccanismo però ho capito dov'è
[Musica]
dov'è la roba là
non posso salire che si di casina lo
stesso notare sulla mensola
no no quasi aveva semplicemente per
accendere nora walker e niente devo
trovare ancora quella roba lì non so
dove sia ragazzi progetto
a c'è un buco la nave visto è una pena
della fai bordello feto posso salire sui
libri non avevo capito allora sì che mi
sa che la scimmia fermi non così
no a zio basta non fare bordello
può aprire la porta lo zio
no no non sto tranquillo perché non so
se può aprire la porta
era
probabilmente no perché l'avrebbe già
fatto
quella porta
faccio questa roba ma devo lanciarla
tipo madonna quanto fai bordello per
onano devo lanciarla tipo la devi
lasciarla per la porta con la apro la
porta dove
non ho idea che la pila tanto tra un
modo per per la porta ma mi chiama amici
voglio io adesso già sicuro non riuscirò
mai non si spegnerà sistema contro
deviata e vabbè mi merito di morire dopo
questo madonna che portavano alla soglia
media aperto la porta lui ha aperto lui
la porta ecco perché che allora spegne
assegnati un silos pegnato venia frate e
di canale 5 20 uomini e donne mettiamo
mille donne che c'è maria metti uomini e
donne
vedi gli piace un biglietto alle varie
espressioni goduta sì ma frate spegne
ma allora sono attirati dai rumori c'è
positivamente
[Musica]
che sei così vuol dire che non la
spegnerà mai quindi con andrea
se fai casino se fai casino datano
dovrebbe sentirmi sulle tegole
[Musica]
tutta la mia sorella non solo usare i
tasti sto gioco di un'ora e mezzo e ci
giocano capito i tasti un'ora e mezza
hanno capito i tasti porca eva devo
tener premuto un tan è difficile un
tasto questo c'è porca vacca non è che
c'è un genio a [ __ ] c'è decenni
[Musica]
ok
oggi su
lo stesso rumore ce n'è un altro ragazzo
mi ha sputato mi incazzo c'è veramente
cosa se l'onorevole ora il piccolo
piccolo ma faccio un board
dell'incredibile era ok vai vai tira
tira finirà ma sono anche a cosa serve
salewa non è un'idea prova bene ma anche
no tutto sopporterò per tirare sul
pianoforte
cazzo veloce
ok
zio veloce sta arrivando il tipo però
celo celo celo celo ok perfetto che culo
mi chiamava lei non ne sono accorto che
stava arrivando se non me la prendevo
comoda
ok ragazzi perfetto e volevi ok qua devo
far scendere un carrello devo saltare
questo la maniglia
5 chiaro il resto carrello qualche caso
hanno messo a ok
le bruciature di culo ragazzi oggi non
me ne prendo grazie facciamo un altro
giorno a che già sono i tizi con le
braccia lunghe e il cervello corto a
rompermi le palle
ci manca solo che mi dopo prenderà
scottatura bravo così ti voglio
bravo bravo così carico è bravo prossimo
tra fatti partire dalle ragnatele ti
attacchi al muro tutto daccapo zio
incastrato nell'albero
che palle di fare tutto daccapo per una
cagata incredibile che rottura di maran
assurda vuoi spiegare il perché quella
stanza lì c'era non c'era niente quel
problema di sostanza
[Musica]
no non ci credo
ok si sta roba
così carlo malacarne la porta al suo
posto
[Musica]
mi sono cagato addosso per il topo che
non me l'aspettavo mai presi sfruttato
il braccio c'era un finto già si era poi
c'è la jobs che al vero
sua madre brutta ma anche ma la cosa che
mi aspettava ma poi scusa questo
spuntarelli dai vertici bacia e
abbraccia perché perché si sia nei muri
c'era non ho capito io
così via in quello è volevi si si tasta
mi sa che il culo se vuoi
o basta toglie
che noioso la tua ragazza deve essere
veramente contenta ci sai fare con le
mani ti sei rotto il cazzo dorigo e
vabbè tutti e due addirittura
mentre per adesso
zio occhio che c'è il tipo è in cura di
brutto
cosa che dice che esce dalla porta ciò
che questo tutti esistenziale come lo è
che chiusa no stavo scherzando
scherzando scherzando scherzando
scherzando che da giugno la donna
madonna l'ansia lazio ma dai ma che
palle ma come l'unico punto che sono
andato io ma [ __ ] dai ma poi un
punto cento quello sbagliato a volte
pare ragazzo ce lo vado qua lava che
faccio
se si scassa quello romanista che ti
partono le braccia dimmi se ti devo
schiaffeggiare schiaffeggiare con l'agi
la famiglia adesso
studio schiaffeggiare la faccia di bit
come cosa preferisce non so se devo
resistere qua dentro
li ha già controllato un minori
controllerà di nuovo dai staccati
quanto ci metto ha scassato
euro mica non va giù a ma qui non va giù
oltre a devo fare quello che pensavo che
si scassa se proprio ragazzo
e non passo ma ci passo zio
dopo stati quattro
ho passato in traghetto cazzo devo
andare mica volte che brutta situazione
è questa
raga non ha capito cosa devo fare giuro
non ho capito giurate sono messo male
malissimo ha forse dopo sarebbe dei tubi
quelli no maraga non ha saputo fare
meglio
dopo italia a sinistra della mano
come hai fatto come ti sei brava stato
la mano come hai fatto come non è
fisicamente possibile fare e va beh
prendi di kick ass tv fai capire cosa
devo fare almeno devo saltare lo devo
fare in modo che i vecchi
come credo saltare se sì cosa c'è un
portello lì però non si apre quindi poi
sono cazzo
e ho provato già
non va
niente ragione non ho capito non so non
so
ha forse forse ho capito forse
no niente non ho capito i giorni
eppure mi sembrava di poter tornare
indietro
che fastidio quando non conosciuto le
robe non so rago aidan fucking nov
non ne ho idea vediamo
mi guardo perché se non siamo quasi una
vita giuro tanto schiaccia rimane sempre
rimarrà sempre impresso mi faccia anche
una micro pausa perché minchia
sto giocando dalla loro e mezza e
navigata per ogni giorno una figata
sara è un po miliardi mettere avvio di
giochi che mi mettono ansia mi danno mi
metto all'ansia e mettono ansia per il
vento all'ansia c'è proprio st problema
di fondo però ok vediamo un po fuori dal
problema il problema è posto come l'area
che se avete problemi di te ma neanche
tanto me ne sbatto il cazzo
ebbe la sua canzone ho cambiato raga la
canzone di fondo dei miei video metto
questa non ci sarebbe arrivato bello
tagliarmi con la soia sono proprio la
bella persona ok a 6 anni particola qua
non è neanche il
esso chiaro
ci sarebbe arrivato ragazzi ancora
pensavamo se finita invece no devo con
scassa prima barca [ __ ] non ha niente
niente neanche le neanche le soluzioni
sono capaci di fare da guardare anche
quel mango quelle mango le soluzioni
avevo visto come la roba che non mi
volevo spegnere altro ma evidentemente
non è non solo quello
ok
si vende sì perché non si vedono anzi
sta vedendo scusatemi sono un pirla non
si vede
[Musica]
è difficile lo stesso anche sapendo cosa
devi fare e difficile sarà
ora come mick ago tutto che sono
attaccato all'angolino tutto cagato
fin qua c'eravamo celav ampiamente non
c'eravamo da brocade poi vi prende al
volo ma che cazzo è ora stiamo già
facciamo pensa non riesco a farla un
sapendo cosa devo fare
adesso devo scoprirlo
[Musica]
dai tana quanto tempo porca [ __ ] un
tasto c'è il bello che il vero io li
schiaccia il tasto dello schiacciare
ogni tanto lo fa ogni tanto no mica un
anno e mezzo da fare una stronzata dai
zio riga è difficile una roba deve fare
siamo qua io continuano a farlo perché
non riesco a casiraghi
questo è il problema delle library e le
parti dove posso tagliare
che palle che questo il tasto per
afferrare porca l'ha colta na afferra
cazzo lo fai a vuoto la volta afferra
volte no capisco il nervoso ma non
capisco da lode o sporca e valenza
appello tira o anche prima era così
perché prima non funziona adesso sì non
lo so ancora che lo faccio adesso la
stessa roba devo fare se funzionasse ora
può funzionare
però a volte funziona a volte non decide
lui piace di torno
ok
berra
e tira a terra e tira e tira
ok
[Musica]
questa parte è stata pisa this facente
di un porno ok ma quanto gol fatto in
quanto modo quanto posso godere di
questa cosa
che figata vi ho staccato le braccia la
tana achievement sbloccato cosa sono
arrivato a metà
che figata staccato le braccia sono
troppo figo chi è troppo non temporale
beh direi che per adesso adesso tag
stavolta raga la concludo qua
continuiamo poi nella prossima live la
prossima live e lo finiamo laga perché
impedendo un bando vrebbero bastare due
live per finirlo gli es
figo e a parte il finale che minchia
fare sta parte l'ho dovuto guardare come
parla e non ci riuscivo quale viviamo
sono rimesso 12 anni si trova dalla
parte di fico fico me piace un sacco
l'inter nightmares veramente figo
continuiamo poi il live la facciamo ve
lo dico subito quando lo facciamo la
prossima live la facciamo
mercoledì 17 per quelli 17 il live
finiamo l'intel nightmares quindi sembra
le 14
no scusate alle 16 quelli alle quattro
di pomeriggio facciamo la seconda parte
di little nightmare e lo finiamo in live
e stavolta citando un po di meno
vabbè ragazzi io vi ringrazio per aver
seguito online
spero che vi sia piaciuto e spero che
questa serie vi sia piaciuta vi stia
piacendo più che altro e come sento dire
non mi piace anche vari social che come
descrizione sono sentiti siete che ci
vediamo al prossimo video è però
effettivamente non so mesto parla live
quindi ci mette un pochettino ok belle
ragazze